it's been six years of
trying times
it's very
strange
when one day your
cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds you're
quasimodo
i'm obsessed with the truth and um so
today is my
actually my the first uh opportunity
that i've been able to
speak about this
um case
in full for the for the first time since
i knew that there was no truth to it
whatsoever
i felt it my responsibility to uh
to stand up
not only for myself
in that instance but stand up for my
children
she was
loving um
she was smart she was
kind she was funny she was understanding
there was a kind of a
joke to not joke but just
[Music]
yeah
i acknowledged the
the fact that i was the old craggy bogey
and she was this
um
[Music]
um
beautiful um
um creature just this
stunning creature there were
arguments
and
things of that nature
but never
did i myself
reach the point of um
striking
misheard in any way
nor have i ever struck
any woman
in my life
my mother was
quite unpredictable
she was very unpredictable
she was a
she had the ability to be
as as cruel as
anyone can be
you
you sort of shield yourself because you
didn't know what was going to happen so
there was there was the physical abuse
which was
a constant um
there was
quite a lot of verbal abuse there was
quite a lot of name calling and
um
bullying
you know
making fun of making fun of
whatever
defect you know
one might have you know my brother wore
glasses
so of course she was
four eyes